this room in a bed-and-breakfast in
Birmingham is all Denise and her five
children have to call home the bed's
take up most of the space just one
double and bunk beds to share between
them I lucky we're not identifying them
and we've changed their names because
Denise left an abusive relationship
they've been living like this for over
five months there's books ten-year-old
Rachel told me she struggles to find
anywhere to do her homework the children
eat whatever they can but this is where
they have to make most of their meals
Denise shows me the kitchen they share
with around 30 other people when we get
there it's already in use back in the
room as I'm talking to nine-year-old
Ethan the worktop behind him collapses
bed-and-breakfast owners know councils
have run out of options and some have
put their prices up figures seen
exclusively by Sky News show councils in
England paid over a hundred and fourteen
million pounds housing people in bed and
breakfasts last year that's more than 20
million pounds more than the year before
and over ten times the amount they were
paying ten years ago councils say they
need help from the government to tackle
the housing shortage crisis including
funding for new homes that covers the
cost of losing council houses through
the right to buy scheme increasingly
councils that have had to make more use
of Bed and Breakfast because
the supply of social housing and
affordable private rented housing is not
there to the extent that we need it
speak the government insists it's
delivered more homes than any year in
the last three decades but counsel
waiting lists keep growing across the
country hundreds of families are having
to live like this by law people with
children shouldn't have to live in
temporary bed-and-breakfast
accommodation any longer than six weeks
but when counselors have nowhere else to
put them they simply have to stay Denise
and her children have no idea how long
they'll have to live like this waiting
and hoping for a better life Becky
Johnson Sky News Birmingham